this land used to be covered by thriving
fields and Orchards
but like many other areas in Iraq's
Southern provinces
drought Has Lifted parched
villages in the district of say detrail
were once a major supplier of meat for
the whole province
explains how a shortage of water has
ruined his farm
his cows are weak and unhealthy because
they drink water that is contaminated
Lush greeneries and fruit including
watermelons in summer and wheat and
barley in Winter our crops die and our
livestock tried to find remains of grass
we've lost 300 cows this year alone in
our area
the Twin Rivers the Tigris and the
Euphrates are a Lifeline for people
living in Iraq
but the water levels have fallen
drastically
that is blamed on dams being built in
Iran and turkey
a less rain falling in recent years
the little water that remains is covered
in riverweed
and contaminated by waste and toxic
chemicals
yet it's the only source for use for
about 70 000 people in this area
Ahmed Jason distributes desalinated
water to those in remote areas
he says demand is the highest it's ever
been
this tank capacity can supply four or
five houses only we have been working on
a daily basis and the demand for
household water has increased
dramatically since 2018
here can only afford a barrel of water a
whole day
even water from artesian wells is salty
this ditch extends for a few kilometers
and used to be full of water now it has
dried up and people from the village
have been digging Wells by hand in its
bed like this one here they then use
pumps like this to get the water to
their homes
but since it's not desalinated people
here say it's harmful especially for
children's skin
some Farmers have moved to other cities
others have changed their profession
and with Summer approaching
those who've chosen to carry on fear
their communities and their way of life
will decline Mahmoud Abdullah al-jazeera
in the vicinity of anasriya City
Southern Iraq